>> Gillian: LETS GO LIVE TO
THE U.S. SOUTHERN BORDER WHERE
NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT SPOKE TO
A GROUP OF MIGRANTS THAT ARRIVE
THERE YESTERDAY.
ONE TOLD FOX NEWS THIS ABOUT HIS
JOURNEY.
>> RIGHT NOW, IT’S A MOMENT THAT
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME
HERE.
>> AS OPPOSED TO MAYBE A YEAR
AGO.
>> JUST NERVOUS, IT’S A HUGE
MOMENT OF WHAT I’M FEELING RIGHT
NOW.
>> Gillian: FOX NEWS IS ON THE
GROUND INSIDE, ACROSS THE
RIO GRANDE RIVER.
HE SET THE SCENE FOR US, WHAT
ELSE ARE WE HEARING AND SEEING
HERE THIS HOUR?
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
SO TODAY WAS THE THIRD DAY IN A
ROW THAT WE’VE SEEN A VERY LARGE
GROUP OF MIGRANTS ACROSS THE
RIO GRANDE AND PRESENT
THEMSELVES TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
HERE ON THE U.S. SIDE OF THE
BORDER.
HAS BECOME QUICKLY ONE OF THE
MOST ACTIVE SECTORS ALL ALONG
THE U.S.-MEXICO BORDER, SHOW YOU
SOME OF THE VIDEOS OF WHAT WE’VE
BEEN WITNESSING THESE LAST THREE
DAYS.
WHAT YOU ARE LOOKING AT HERE,
THIS WAS THE BIGGEST GROUP OF
MIGRANTS WE HAVE SEEN SO FAR, A
GROUP OF 52 VENEZUELANS WHO
CROSS THE RIO GRANDE WHEN THE
WATER WAS RUNNING LOWER AND IT’S
MUCH SAFER AND YOU CAN SEE SOME
OF THEM HALVED INFANTS AND
STRUGGLING IN THE CURRENT LITTLE
BIT BUT HAD A CHANCE TO TALK TO
SOME OF THESE FOLKS, ONE FAMILY
TELLING ME THEY CROSSED INTO
COLUMBIA THEN PAID SOMEBODY TO
TAKE A FLIGHT INTO MEXICO, THEN
TOOK A BUS CLOSER TO THE BORDER
CROSSING WHERE WE ARE AT RIGHT
NOW, MANY OF THESE VENEZUELANS
TELLING US THAT THEY FEAR THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN VENEZUELA
AND THEY WANT A BETTER LIFE SO
THEY CAME HERE TO THE
UNITED STATES.
TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT ONE MAN
TOLD US AS TO WHY HE CAME HERE
WITH HIS WIFE AND TWO YOUNG
CHILDREN.
>> I WANT SECURITY.
THAT’S WHAT I WANT.
I WANT SECURITY FOR US AND MY
FAMILY AND HELP OUR LIFE.
>> YOU CAN HEAR THAT MAN GETTING
EMOTIONAL THEY ARE.
WHAT WE’VE SEEN EVERY DAY IS
VIDEO YOU ARE LOOKING AT NOW
WHICH IS THAT LOCAL SHERIFF’S
DEPUTIES ARE HAVING TO SORT
THROUGH THESE MIGRANTS WHEN THEY
FIRST PRESENT THEMSELVES HERE
BECAUSE BORDER CONTROL ISN’T
HERE RIGHT NOW.
THEY ARE NOT WAITING FOR THESE
MIGRANTS.
THEY HAVE TO GET CALLED IN AND
BECAUSE THEY ARE SO OVERWHELMED
AND OVEREXTENDED, IT CAN
SOMETIMES TAKE AN HOUR OR TWO
FOR BORDER PATROL TO ARRIVE SO
THESE LOCAL SHERIFF’S DEPUTIES
HAVE TO DO THE SORTING THAN THEY
HAND THEM OFF THE BORDER PATROL
AND IF YOU PULL UP THAT VIDEO,
THAT’S GOING TO BE WHAT YOU’RE
LOOKING AT IS A BORDER CONTROL
BUS.
WHEN BORDER PATROL DOES ARRIVE,
THESE DEPUTIES HAND THEM OFF AND
THEY BRING A BIG BUS AND THAT’S
WHEN THEY END UP GETTING
PROCESSED BUT HE IS FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE WHILE HIS DEPUTIES ARE
HELPING BORDER CONTROL DO THIS
AND APPREHENDING THESE MIGRANTS,
THEY DON’T HAVE TIME TO RESPOND
TO LOCAL CALLS FOR SERVICE HERE
IN THE COUNTY, THEY ARE HERE
DOING THIS SO THE SHERIFF IS
FRUSTRATED AND HE WANTS THEM TO
SEND SOME HELP HER FIGURE
SOMETHING ELSE TO TAKE A LISTEN
TO WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
>> IT IS TYING UP RESOURCES AND
FRUSTRATING BECAUSE THERE IS NO
ANSWERS THAT ARE BEING GIVEN.
I DON’T BELIEVE THERE’S A PLAN
IN PLACE.
RIGHT NOW, WE NEED MORE
MANPOWER, PEOPLE IN D.C. TO MAKE
A DECISION AND DO THEIR JOB.
>> THAT’S HERE IN THE DEL RIO
SECTOR IF YOU PULL UP THIS VIDEO
VIDEO, SHOT SOUTH OF US DOWN IN
THE RIO GRANDE VALLEY THIS
MORNING WHERE BORDER AGENTS ON
HORSEBACK HAD TO TRACK DOWN A
GROUP OF ABOUT A DOZEN MIGRANTS
FROM THE TRIANGLE COUNTRIES,
TAKE THEM INTO CUSTODY BACK OUT
HERE LIVE, THIS IS HAPPENING ALL
ALONG THE U.S.-MEXICO BORDER IN
ALMOST EVERY SECTOR HERE, REALLY
PICKING UP THE LOCAL SHERIFF’S
SAYINGS NEVER IN HIS LIFE HAS HE
SEEN THE IMMIGRATION SITUATION
GET THIS BAD.
WE WILL SEND IT BACK TO YOU.